[Applause]
[Applause]
yes Barbara please I could have jumped
in but I'm gonna I don't think weights
doing very well yes I agree man Barbara
is killing us she's so she's good she's
she's she's beating us soundly yeah look
man look at that play baby what a
goddamn miracle it's find a year new
year new me I feel like you need to take
a breath a little bit and relax I'm fine
thanks going everything's going very
happily can't you must be happy for our
friend your friend Barbara oh man oh
let's jump in just snappy reflexes Wow
whoa all right that's fair good play man
good play by good play I guess you might
get it
I had some winners over there though you
oh thank you for playing that particular
number had none much appreciate our was
channeling I was challenging you and you
roast the challenge good job but look
here's another challenge for you can you
do bar brothers of goddamn jumping
Oh what other drawers the man sweet baby
Jesus let me see was it was it telling
you no it's mine
yellow though in her hand watch out for
that [ __ ] alright well it's not it's not
either of those things
good guess mark good guess I want the
cards you know what I don't want such a
good hand to be out here like this
Mark's got two blues out spoiling what I
got and I don't have those you lying
anyway not only blues left don't don't
let don't listen to him oh good play
barb you might want to listen lay a
little bow oh dear
listening well what a play
big blue tough call tough call call I
think I'm gonna do this guy let's do
that wait stop yellow okay it's got a
yellow to everybody you don't know that
maybe I was bluffing that's uh that's a
possibility you know cuz you're [ __ ]
called [ __ ]
that's a good that's a good play that's
art that's nice that's Sandy what stage
of grief do you think you're on right
now wait you're leaving anger so yeah
I'm moving close to whatever crying hit
what stage is that oh good play look at
those skip stacking them up that Barbara
Oh does she have it no I've got a lot of
yellows and plus twos cuz yourself no I
think you're lashing out at us and what
have we done to you yeah enabled Barbara
you put you put the the scythe in her
hand that she could decapitate me that's
true you are the nuke and it gave her
the new controller yeah okay can you
explain and keep explaining how does
this work you the dirt and shovel and my
hole you know what that was a bold move
thank you
I tried real hard got real don't get so
hard
right you right right
no baby obey Oh got him all right okay
all right that's interesting unit color
it was better than this
Barbara challenged it come on man she's
not gonna challenge it and no way all
right wait what you got all I've got red
well okay I guess I just got this all
right come on out that oh that's good
no there's a good one let's make that
happen
[Laughter]
do we need to stop play this game no oh
look at that two blue two tough one
tough one I think he's gonna have to
draw Oh bold move coming out with the
three look at that all right yeah I play
that that's good let's make it read some
more like red suede wait look at those
good card you're getting though valuable
those can you say one nice thing to
Barbara just one person you've ever seen
that's nice now oh okay I got you boo
waiting green eyes they are both eyes
okay cards over there when I look at
your smile I hardly noticed tooth all
right oh look at that Wow man I think I
know the truth
okay that's a good one that was the
truth all right
me I've got my end marker do they want
the truth of my hand I don't love
[ __ ] one thing I want you to Ruth
wait
Oh would you do this oh why would you do
that that's not good for me I don't give
a [ __ ] what's good for you my friend
that's so a grabber you're my brother
friend my sweet succulent signals
friends there you go yeah wait your your
rage is straight up breaking your
microphone okay I'm gonna give you
another chance all right I'm down I'm
fine how are you deep breaths except the
love love oh look at that you know you
had the fewest cards in your hand but
that's well thank God we're all back to
six again it's just game just started
again you right that's fine that's fine
wait get er okay oh sweet I'll say
something nice about you - I love the
way the light shines off the top of your
head uh-huh that's what Barbara said to
me I didn't hear that
so you're sort of imagining Barbara
talking near wick you know she's not a
real person right you do okay wait you
lose your grip a little bit here listen
wait I've got a solution I'm too old I'm
confident play out I don't want
sacrifice you made Bob I'm so proud of
you wait did you say thank you that's
not a good color I don't like that color
all right oh my goodness you know you
couldn't have done that I love green
good [ __ ] Wow Wow [ __ ] much to think
about what you just succeed what what do
you what do you know mark that's that's
not the best color I mean that's fine I
guess
Wow well if you're gonna act like that
no seven what no I don't smile anymore
mark you know what to do yeah Oh play
twice thank God for that those twos
coming out strong no Barbara no don't
lose my plus floor say she's got a red
and a +4 well I'm gonna go with that
then good one just for one's choice no
choice we're on the same team being that
were not on teams
threes fours and sixes ah no well I'm
just gonna a short circuit this then all
right fair enough
well done well good job well done that
was a good one that was a hard-fought
game you know I went on and around of
you and us anyway wait what the [ __ ] do
you want just fall on that grenade for
you right now it's okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you thank you mark my good friend
like the problem solve the three goddamn
cards you got I got I got one of those
that's alright what why didn't you get
to go again I'm confused
Barbara jumped in oh okay wait so you
can calm down it's fine everything's
fine this is a pretty good one I'll say
that again
pretty much oh no Barbara's gonna do it
for me Wow harsh play tough play yeah
Barbara coming in real spicy there feel
like you had a blue though the world
will never know now yeah that's okay
sorry you click on it you know I know
but I would panicked all right
I wasn't prepared for it to be nice to
all bar but don't you dare drop a pork
shoulder oh good good play bar a very
well my [ __ ] hand now is the
time on sprockets when feed no I think
we all know what's gonna happen
all right I didn't have any yellow so
you really saved me there I know I did
yah Oh God you had kept that straw too
[ __ ] Savage damn you really ruined it
that's oh that's rough man
whoa that's a spicy meatball that's what
that is
what you gonna do great pick yeah I got
some rad spy it's scary one wait Gus
quiet but he's not actually muted it's
good starting in a different way I think
it's my kind against okay that's
probably fine he's probably thinking
like don't OS or something like that I'm
not the only one who had to live through
this with my whole trouble experience
Barbra well I don't know if you're a lot
to donate for that undone on Twitter
look you need to calm down wait I'm just
gonna let mark go for a second I think
war is a bunch of bits in honor of
Barbara and I mean I don't want anything
there's no about a [ __ ] TV slash
minions 777 and letting them let way
know how much you love Barbara yeah I
mean this is a game of togetherness oh
good play you can do it barb oh can you
do it no here wait well how do you try
you try you try you try can you get god
this fight her off yeah that's the
spirit
Oh about your sodium levels checked Oh
barb it's your time that you'd never
know it's still your time till your time
barb everyone wants you to play even
wade oh wow
oh wait you're gonna read those Dodos
you got a pill did rod Barbara bits bit
the [ __ ] god damn it what is this I
don't want it take it back
cut refund bits I don't think so man
well
well this quilt well oh wow that's weird
don't worry about it what's uh what's
bar what's barb got over there I forget
oh but well I'll remember for you it's a
red five could play man oh well all
right this is a well yeah right behind
you I was gonna let that [ __ ] through
well I don't have any Reds I'm just
kidding I've got some Reds [ __ ] no
it's okay man just you play your own
well apparently not
yeah five that we knew she had no one
[ __ ] knows it's okay not knowing
thank you Bob for encouraging all those
goddamn bars I was I was getting bits
man I'm fine goddamn hairs that just
fell out or definitely worth that six
bucks go again back to the start of the
game ladies and gentlemen I don't have
any God we're fortunate oh you say you
don't have red sorry sorry yeah yeah
Green's good Green's good now that I
think about it greens not that good
man I was really bad I was happier than
I am by blues fine who's fine who's fine
how do you like blue wait like wow we're
so aggressive all thank you for the bits
for Barbara thank you crystalline thank
you so much I remember all of your names
and Oh goddamn naughty list
[Laughter]
good move I done for me though all right
play are you [ __ ] me
yeah I am why what's this - it just
copies the last card great let's keep it
red
good well good play ooh savage play
about that oh all right good [ __ ]
play let's play that nope let's play
that no let's play that all right Oh
Barbara just donated a dollar and say
it's all [ __ ] Barbara's fault you
right this is Barbara's fault
stop what no you know what the second
part of it my key right when he write
here I can't do it I can't do it man
savage plays coming out of Barbara's
corner over there oh man oh man all
right that's a lot of suffice got any
blue stuff in there well that's not
that's rude well I'm keeping that one
Wow it was fun it was fun mark don't
want to keep it
oh you're really gonna enjoy that hand
no way come on come on don't [ __ ] me oh
that's harsh harsh that's our shop level
[ __ ] right there well oh man ex just
oh wow well and it's blue - that's not a
good color
oh there we go nice yeah nice nice
thanks man get them bar nice
come on wait play something bit say
there were four Barbie titties is that a
Barbara bits I don't know what that
means
yeah that's a little that's a little odd
why is everyone on the Gundam tee
Barbara she's but an ass
to everybody no no the same thing for
the donation here's some money take
Barbara for a wonderful night yeah
[ __ ] $5.00 get her a goddamn footlong
well that sounds weird I'll get these
burgers yeah uh-huh you know wait you
and Barb can do whatever you want your
yeah we will I assume oh my god
there's no way [ __ ] you I thought so you
still take four that's fine four I'm not
I'm not getting savaged here all on my
life this Handa fine
what is this [ __ ] I'm looking at all
right there's a four for you mark this
will you calm this down will you bring
this back to order
I will that nine was a smart play oh
thank you
that green that green switch though look
at that I feel like nothing's a good
choice thanks for burning that seven
your hand for it sir let's wait don't
don't be don't be mean don't be mean
that's all insane that's this little
slap that's a little slap on the wrist
general rule life don't be mean and wait
I feel like don't be mean don't be mean
weird
[Applause]
wowie
sweet good teas goodness spicy beans oh
no two seconds what the [ __ ] Wow wowie
wow wow
all right blue blues good okay whose
[ __ ] you Barbara take this goddamn
[ __ ] I don't know if you really want
her hand either Oh barb what are you
gonna do to me Oh barb that's rough all
right you want to play a game what kind
of game know if you'll see you'll see
you'll see all right I don't know how to
play this game over you
you can't lose no you can't lose me Wade
mostly Wade I'm like the friendly news
people I'm always would have jumped in
and saved my ass there I could have
jumped in why would I possibly waste an
extra draw I like that game I'm trying
to make sure we don't run on cards wait
I want to keep this day as possible oh
nice nice nice oh well your hand back
Marc that's play one of those that's
good all right follow it up with one of
those well she got that okay that's fine
all right
nobody we just let you win let me let
you win by something that you did yes I
don't recall you doing anything I can't
do again I can't good
I'm god no
[Music]
you